[Music]
jj
articulated our mission so clearly
and it's really meaningful for me to
have this codified now into the fiber of
our organization and to be recognized as
a b
corp but what i really want to emphasize
is that our contributions to the open
source
are funded by professional customers and
their commitment to our professional
tooling
so that's why the successes of our
professional customers
are so important their wins
are all of our wins within the entire
community
so today i'm going to talk about ways
that i've seen our professional
customers
overcome common pain points that can
that can trip up a team and limit their
ability to become
efficient data-driven organizations
so a year ago i sat in this audience
like many of you maybe as an engineer
and a data scientist working in industry
and i was trying to find out for my own
how to make my analysis
more powerful more efficient more
impactful
and it's just funny how things turn out
not too long after conf
i had the opportunity to move to our
studio and now i'm working with
professional customers who are asking
those same questions
so in the time that i've been at our
studio i've had
a lot of customer conversations so far
well over 200 right now i'm averaging
about 8 to 10 meetings a week
and our customers span across every
industry that you can imagine
in my role i get a unique insight into
the various stages of a data science
team's
growth and their maturations and the
challenges that they face
sometimes that team i'm talking to is
literally a team of one and
some of these teams are spanning the
globe
they have enterprise level architectures
and data products in place
but i do see common elements among these
teams and across all industries i've
gotten a firsthand view
into some of the successes that take a
team from good to great
so i'm going to share two stories from
teams that are
at different maturity levels but they've
succeeded in overcoming significant pain
points
so we can take broad strokes and talk
about phases of
maturity in the data science team now
our first phase right these these are
our
fun excited newbie teams right they're
establishing buy-in for their analytics
they're establishing
credibility for what they're doing maybe
they're coming off of excel and
spreadsheet-based things
but there's a lot of big and easy wins
for them as they start to explore what
they can do with all the capabilities of
working
in a codified analytics means so
this group i love they're just dazzled
by all the amazing things that they can
do with code
our phase two teams are a little further
along in the path
right at this point they've established
buy-in
they've got credibility often they're
growing in size they've got more people
on the team maybe they're adding more
data products to their portfolio
but definitely no matter what's going on
their data products have been
recognized as being more business
critical
right they've got cred behind what
they're doing and that's
great but along with that comes greater
expectations
and more demand and so now these teams
are in this state of figuring out
what the hell have we done and how are
we going to keep this up
we're not sure what we've gotten
ourselves into and there's a lot of
growing pains associated with the phase
two teams
and then lastly there's that upper
echelon phase three team right
they are hitting on all cylinders
they've got it all
figured out and i think there's
definitely an asthmatic path
that phase two teams take towards
becoming a phase three but
really no one actually gets it all
figured out in the end
so the two teams i'm going to talk about
today team one is a phase one team
they're moving from an excel world
they've got really inefficient reporting
emailing things around but they've
discovered
shiny and so they're enthusiastic about
this but they're really struggling to
figure out
how to get their data products into
their consumer's hands from here
team two is gonna be a phase two team
and
they're trying to maintain an efficient
workflow as they grow
but they're finding some issues because
they're becoming a little too cavalier
in their approach so when teams are
tangled up
looking for answers to these types of
questions
it can take weeks or months or sometimes
years to overcome these issues
you get the benefit of 2020 hindsight
and reflection
and you could see these struggles and
have visibility of their success
strategies
i want you to walk away from this talk
with enough information
and vision that you can see that there's
a forward path
for your own team and i invite you to
come to the lounge at some point this
week
and have a deeper and more specific
conversation
about how to move your own team to the
next level
now since we're talking professional
customers we need to have a quick
orientation
on our rstudio professional products so
our studio
offers three professional products our
studio server pro
connect and package manager
these products provide a modular
platform
which provide the shortest and the most
efficient path
for lasting value in a data science team
for all
entities so our studio server pro is
your place for r
in python data analysis now supporting
jupiter sessions
as well as traditional r studio session
connect is a publication platform and
this is where all the data products that
are created go to live
where stakeholders can consume and
interact with those data products
and our studio package manager provides
a managed and
controlled environment for your packages
but at the core
of this are the open source packages
that we're dedicated to
now let me introduce you to our phase
one team so
they had a handful of analyses all tied
up in excel files they used to email
them around it
bogged things down tremendously but
they've discovered shiny
and they have jumped wholeheartedly on
board
but the biggest issue facing this team
is now needing a way to get their shiny
app into the hands of their stakeholders
so it could be used
so for a little while they were simply
publishing to localhost
and it quickly became apparent that that
was not a stable
or scalable solution but they also
weren't
sure if they were going to need to be
reliant on an outside group
to be able to help get their apps
published so
for them a win is being able to have
their work
visible and discoverable by their
stakeholders
and really success in this realm would
open up the door
for this group to be able to reach their
broader goals of securing buy-in for
what they're doing
so they can expand their scope and their
impact in the organization they can get
off of this repetitive
just updating the same quarterly report
every
every quarter and get into more forward
thinking and proactive analysis
so my phase one team found that our
studio connect
provided the best home for their data
products
what was really appealing to them was
the ease of deployment
so connect permits push button
deployment from the ide
right from this little blue button
that's really small on your screen here
but what you do you push this button and
all of your packages
and your r version information is
bundled up
behind the scenes shipped off to the
connect server
and unpacked and so deployment as easy
as
pushing a button and two minutes later
you're off and running
now once this team shiny app was
available on connect stakeholders could
interact with all this information in a
self-service manner
and it didn't require these iterations
going back to the data scientists time
and time again whenever they wanted to
see a different view
or a different variable
but what was really great to see with
this team
was that they really began to leverage
the multiple data types supported by
connect
so for them connect opened the door to
new gains for them
so in addition to this original shiny
app
they discovered they could tackle all
sorts of other
inefficiencies in their processes
they're using
scheduled and ad hoc reporting and our
markdown and using jupyter notebooks
sending customized emails using pens
as part of an etl process so i want to
show what this would look like as a
as an example so
in connect for report scheduling when
you upload and you're working within our
markdown document
or a jupyter notebook you have the
ability to specify
both the report frequency and the
audience for which you want to send that
report to
and it can be stored just on the connect
server or it can be emailed out
automatically now this team's also
integrated
in condition based triggers so
on some reports it'll only send an email
out
if a certain criteria is met say if it's
a low
inventory condition or if there's
performance threshold criteria that
are being exceeded
another workflow they've fully taken
advantage of is using scheduled r
markdowns
to write etl data to a pen and so this
data lives
right in connect and it's accessed by
their scripts they can control
who has access to this data on the pin
and because it's ephemeral data it
didn't really make a lot of sense
to take this little chunk of data and
put it into a database
but they didn't want to be saving and
importing csv files
and so for them a pin was a perfect
solution
this data is then accessed by their
shiny app
and now they have a regular update cycle
behind their main data product
so the information is always fresh and
relevant
so my team one channeled their
enthusiasm
of moving to a codified solution and
they found
tremendous efficiency gains in value-add
by getting their workflow streamlined
and their products right into the hands
of their customers
now it's time to meet our phase 2 team
so this is a fun bunch
they've grown in their data offerings
they've established credibility in the
organization
for what they do but they're in an
awkward spot
because as their data products are
becoming more business critical
they're finding that their phase one
days of doing things is not sustainable
they've been burned a few times by
pushing things
straight into production and things have
gone awry
they know that they need to start
adopting more process
rigor being more diligent about version
control
but right now it's just hard to let go
of those freewheeling days
of phase one and it just seems like a
jumble of pieces that don't have a clear
order where they need to fall
this team's biggest challenges include
tool and process-based issues but a big
part of it is also philosophy
because of the high visibility of the
past fumbles that they had in pushing
straight to production
they're now butting heads with i.t over
deployment strategies
so it was really uneasy with the push
button deployment feature of connect
it was a little too easy to send things
out to production
that was what made connect such a great
cell
in the phase one days but now it's the
source of friction
so in this case it put out a nine page
list of instructions to
follow in order to deploy to production
and they figured
hey if anyone's diligent enough to go
through online pages they'd pass
their test and they could be trusted to
publish
clearly this did not go well with the
data scientists team
and they just felt this overall turmoil
of
what have we done and how are we going
to keep this thing
going conversations between the data
scientists
and it felt like data scientists are
from mars and it's from venus
words like jenkins and devops were
swirling around in their heads and it
was just overwhelming for them
so a win for this team is to establish a
managed deployment workflow that was
still
efficient but it was respectful and
cognizant of a more
formalized understanding of what
production means
and if they could be successful in this
realm this helps them achieve higher
goals
building a foundation of best practices
and a collaborative relationship with
their i.t
team but i want to tease out a little
bit on this philosophy issue
that really feeds into phase two's team
points
so what is production it can kind of
feel like that summer family road trip
of like
are we there yet where are we going and
frankly how do you know when you're
actually
there so right now you might be having a
hard time
formalizing what it means to be in
production
and if this idea of production sounds
kind of nebulous
you're not alone look around and if you
know
clearly in your head what production
means raise your hand
it's it's a quiet audience right now
guaranteed if you ask 10 different
groups
what production and production readiness
means to them
you're going to get 10 different answers
so let's talk about what production
might mean
an incomplete concept of production only
considers that the data product
is accurate and it's ready to be used
for informing business decisions so
this is where my phase 2 team got bit
they made the mistake of saying it works
fine on my desktop it's ready to go
and if that doesn't get your spidey
senses all tingly what if i tell you it
was a friday afternoon when they said
that
and it was right before an
organizational
deadline so in my customer conversations
i've seen a number of in-house solutions
yet no one really knows what it means to
be
in production and then as demand for
products grow it becomes increasingly
important
and painful to address scaling and
security stability availability
these in-house solutions tend to crumble
as higher demand is placed on them
so a more formally defined state of
production not only ensures that the
data product is correct
but that's in a stable environment it's
safe it's secure
and it scales and responds appropriately
these are the infrastructure things
but there's also a state of mind
associated with production
and this is important in production
you're thinking
ahead and expecting that every change
you make has the potential to disrupt
so you're designing your testing and
your architecting
to prevent that
now my phase two team they were already
working with our studio connect and they
saw how this could provide that stable
secure
scalable wear for production we've got
built-in authentication
access management app by app performance
tuning
they're also able to stand up a staging
environment on qa which was great but
taking advantage of these infrastructure
controls was one
thing but the transformation happened as
the team
cultivated their production readiness
mindset and incorporated best practices
with version control
all in line in an automated dev test
prod workflow
and that was a mouthful so i want to
illustrate what this workflow looks like
because it's very versatile and it's
useful for many teams
so what this means team 2 has linked
their master repo in github
to the production instance of connect
and connect is
automatically watching that repo and
updating it if changes occur
however all development feature editions
and whatnot are worked
off a branch to that master so the
branch repository is deployed to a
staging environment
and this way the data scientists can
still see and touch and feel
and play with their deployed content
without
disruption to the production instance
when this content in the branch is
approved and ready to be moved to
production a pull request is made to
merge the master
and connect automatically redeploys the
updated version
so this automated dev test prod workflow
met the data scientists needs
for an efficient workflow and it met the
requirements
of it for a managed strategy that
allowed
qa in a production mindset and this
philosophy change
an automated workflow has been a
tremendous value add for team two
i've got a quick illustration of it
just to show what it looks like in
connect there was a lot of clicking so i
didn't feel like i could show it live
today but you can see there's
multiple versions of an app of a version
and so in github
we switch to the development branch for
the asset and initiate a pull request
when the merge request is approved then
we move to connect
and i know that this content is get
backed because in the info panel on
connect
it will show me the branch or the the
repository that it's watching
and it will periodically check for
updates or in this case i can force
an update because i know that there's
changes coming so get sees those changes
connect sees those changes and redeploys
and so now we can see that the changes
that we made in production that were
approved are now available and ready for
us in production
okay close things up here
so i want to close with a few thoughts i
do not
want impostor syndrome to get you there
are plenty of sexy and intimidating
words out there when we talk data
science in the enterprise
hadoop and docker kubernetes spark and
slurm
it's okay you don't have to know
or understand it all because successful
enterprise data analytics teams are just
that they're team so you do what you do
best but
build up count on communicate and learn
with your team you need an r admin you
need it and devops and you need to be
listening to your stakeholders
so to recap what i want you to see today
is you can have your own success story
and i want you to benefit from seeing
some solutions and common pain points
that might confront you along the way
it's important that you find an
efficient way to share your data
products
work smart use automation and
reproducibility to make efficient
workflows
and know where you're going on this
journey to production and bring the
whole team along
and above all i want you to think
forward ask questions
and come visit us at the lounge for a
more detailed conversation
thank you katie um so i forgot to
mention if you have any questions
uh the best way to ask them is just to
go to sly.do
and we're in track number three imperial
room
so i think we just have time for one
question before the next speaker
so there's a couple questions that came
in but one of them was
so what do you think are some ways that
data science teams can accelerate their
learning
and especially adopt newer open source
packages they may not have used before
like plumber or tensorflow
i i really enjoy it sounds so
fundamental but i
i i find that the best learning happens
when folks go to
the um main landing pages for each of
these packages
so people may not realize but the the
home page for shiny
for our markdown there's a getting
started um section there
with tremendous tutorials um i'll say my
first shiny app i
built by copying pasting code from stack
overflow probably like maybe your first
shiny app
and after watching the tutorials on just
one tutorial from the shiny page i
started a shiny app from blank's
like page and i knew every element and
where it needed to go so
i think the resources are out there um
and fundamentally a lot of the
the building blocks of knowledge that
people can benefit from are right on
those main pages for the packages
awesome thank you